The protests that have consumed Hong Kong for more than three months started because of a proposed bill
that would have made it easier for mainland China to extradite citizens from this semi-autonomous city.
Violent clashes between protesters and police culminated in a confrontation
at a subway station on August 31st when police appeared to beat demonstrators with batons
possibly resulting in one fatality, though
authorities dispute that claim.
The activists, politicians, and academics we spoke with
said that the protest movement has become about much more than the extradition bill,
which the government has since withdrawn.
It's a fight for the survival of an island of liberalism in the shadow of an increasingly authoritarian super state
with ambitions of global dominance.
We are at the frontline between the greatest dictatorship in human history
which is CCP, and the free world.
And Hongkongers, we've shown that we stand with the free world.
And, of course, we hope the rest of the free world
can support us
in this battle
in this war between dictatorship
and freedom.
Hong Kong's peculiar one country two systems governance model
began when Britain handed over its former colony to China in 1997
on the condition that it be allowed to maintain its existing governance structure for another half-century.
This city of more than 7 million prospered economically with China mostly holding up its end of the bargain.
Hong Kong's Constitution protects freedom of speech and assembly,
but the city enjoys what's been
described as liberty without democracy.
The government, including the city's chief executive, isn't entirely elected by the people.
If you did this interview with me in 1997 and asked me,
when did you expect that people in Hong Kong would get this universal suffrage?
I think most people at the time would say, well maybe 10 years. That was almost like part of the promise,
in the basic law. But as time goes by, you know, promises were broken.
Though he supports the universal suffrage, Charles Mok wasn't elected by popular vote
to his position in Hong Kong's legislature but rather selected by a smaller pool
by a smaller pool of stakeholders as an official representative of the city's tech sector.
Like Mok, the majority of representatives didn't get there via the ballot box,
and not surprisingly most members of the legislature who were not voted in by the citizens
side with mainland China and not the protesters.
As one journalist put it, Hong Kong is controlled by a conspiracy of local tycoons and mainland communists
colluding against the citizenry. So the citizenry has turned to the streets.
Largely because we are not a democracy. Because the government is not elected
I think street level protests, largely peaceful, are actually important means for the Hong Kong people
to protest government actions.
And protest has often worked.
The 2014 Umbrella Movement led the government to withdraw a proposal to pre-select
a limited slate of presidential candidates.
And the recent uprising led to the withdrawal of the extradition bill.
The 2014 protests also spawned a mostly youth-led movement to increase democracy
as a way of preserving the city's autonomy.
Joshua Wong was just 15 when he led a successful movement overturning a plan
to impose a pro Communist Party history curriculum in Hong Kong schools.
He then started the political organization, Demosisto.
Which has played a central role in the protest movement and even elected a candidate to office,
who, along with other youth activists elected in 2016, were later disqualified from serving.
At their swearing-in ceremony last month Sixtus Leung and Yayoi Ching unfurled banners
calling for an independent Hong Kong.
To people who support Hong Kong independence
logically
we cannot find a way out
One of the more controversial youth leaders is 'Sixtus' Baggio Leung
who is part of a right-leaning movement advocating for full independence from mainland China.
I don't think Hong Kong can survive
if people around the world
don't trust our system
They don't trust
they will be safe
when they travel to Hong Kong
or do business in Hong Kong
Why would they come?
And why would they need us?
So to keep separation from China
keep a distance from China
to try to be more
of a natural state
is the best solution.
But the problem of course is that there seems to be no institutional channel by which you can do this.
And also I don't see, really tangible movements to actually make that into a reality.
So a lot of that is just talk.
Leung's pro-independence position is still considered radical in Hong Kong.
And experts point out that Chinese state-controlled media often highlights independence activists
in an attempt to portray the protests as part of a radical separatist movement in need of violent suppression.
They're using this sort of propaganda to cater to the domestic audience to justify
for the kind of force they use on Hong Kong.
Do you think that strategy might backfire on China?
It is backfiring.
More and more people in Hong Kong particularly a portion of the young people
are beginning to say that I'm only a Hong Konger.
it's all because of this action reaction the more you push the more I want to break away.
If Hong Kong remained
under the ruling of the Chinese Communist Party
we can never achieve universal suffrage
separation of power,
freedom of speech
all kids of freedom.
We see the 96% of the entertainment scene silencing themselves
and really just trying to keep out of trouble.
Pop singer Denise Ho is one of the few local celebrities who is publicly supporting the protesters.
Others like Jackie Chan and Liu Yifei,
the star of Disney's live-action Mulan reboot,
have praised the Hong Kong police and criticized the demonstrators for being too destructive.
Right now we are at a point where the communist government they do not accept this stance of neutrality.
For them staying silent means that you are with the protesters.
They are trying to force everyone to choose a side. Most of the people they would be afraid to
go against this huge machine because everyone wants a piece of the Chinese market.
Ho has been banned from performing in the mainland.
She says her records have also been removed from Chinese stores,
and some of her international shows have been cancelled  because of alleged security concerns.
Mainland China detained employees of a Hong Kong bookstore known for selling literature
critical of the Communist Party on dubious charges.
Prospective candidates with certain controversial views are barred from running for office.
Leaders of the protests have been imprisoned,
and there's talk of making it illegal for Hong Kong residents to boo the Chinese national anthems
such as that this recent soccer match.
The core values that we are safeguarding
are the freedom to speak our minds,
to take our political stance to protest without fear of being prosecuted.
That has been something that has been given to us in
the earlier days as a British colony.
A lot of Hong Kong people think that like
15 years ago
we had a higher level of freedom,
of freedom of speech or
various other aspects.
But now it seems that we can feel a Hong Kong becoming more and more like China.
In terms of political values
I always believe that one of
the biggest differences between Hong Kong
and the Beijing government is the emphasis on rule of
law, freedom of speech, human rights
and also, maybe, to a lesser extent
democracy.
Activists see the fight for more democracy as a path to securing more Liberty.
They're demanding the citizens be allowed to fully elect the city's legislative body and chief executive.
But winning that right
requires approval from Beijing.
It's really not only about Hong Kong and
Hong Kong government
or the communist government behind it,
it's really a fight of these universal values
that we as a more hybrid city might be aligned with a
lot of different Western societies
and then the set of communist values that
the Chinese government
and maybe even other authoritarian governments around the world
they are trying to bring into the world with their powers.
Personally I feel this is a very global fight
of  these two different sets of values.
The activists are also appealing for help from the US.
Denise Ho, Joshua Wong of Demosisto
and some other pro-democracy activists appeared before a U.S. Congressional committee on Sept 17th
and urged US lawmakers to
pass the Hong Kong Human Rights and Democracy Act,
which would make the city's bilateral trade and travel agreements with America
contingent on China maintaining Hong Kong's autonomy.
It would also levy sanctions against
Chinese individuals
accused of violating the rights of Hong Kong citizens
and would instruct immigration officials not to punish visa applicants.
who've been arrested for participating in the protests.
With America already in a trade war with China such a move could escalate tensions
but advocates say it would be easy for China to comply.
The Hong Kong issue is quite different
from the trade war.
The Hong Kong issue
The Hong Kong issue is actually preventable.
After the U.S. passes the law
it's up to China to decide.
They can just do what they did in the past.
They do not have to tighten control on Hong Kong.
At the moment I have to say
that I'm pretty pessimistic
because it's just so difficult to stop China from extending the kind of power and control that they wish for.
particularly with the current leader of the country, Xi Jinping,
he seems to be a very much of a
total control type of mentality type of person.
In a way I think many of us are
probably even thinking that
what we're trying to do right now is to slow down
the change in the wrong direction
preserving whatever we've got through the one country, two system at the moment.
Despite that pessimism the movements
leaders say they have no choice
but to keep fighting for liberty and democracy or else Hong Kong will be subsumed into an authoritarian state.
There's only win or not win
If we lose,
we lose a generation.
This generation, they will be
put into jail
they will be harassed.
So all or nothing.
And now or never.
There is a Cantonese saying
that this is the end game of the Hong Kong people.
If they do not take to the streets
they will have no future for the next generation.